welcome back Vegas Test Kitchen is
celebrating its second anniversary this
weekend and it's a party you don't want
to miss here to tell us all about it is
Vegas Test Kitchen founder Julie minina
and Chef Bobby Meader from stay tuned
Burgers you guys thank you so much for
being here
well happy two years Jolene tell us
really quickly about Vegas Test Kitchen
and how it feels to have the support of
the Vegas Community I mean it's amazing
that we made it to two years starting
launching during the pandemic we didn't
know if this concept would work right
and it's the Vegas house kitchen is an
incubator for shafts we give them an
opportunity to come in test their
Concepts get some you know feedback from
the community and you know they can
decide are they gonna move on and open a
restaurant or you know maybe go back to
work you know this gives them that
chance without the crazy overhead it's
such a cool concept and people are
loving it I hear such great things about
it and Chef Bobby I'm going to bring you
into the conversation here because
everything is smelling amazing in here
tell us what you're cooking for us today
so yeah I do Smash Burgers every
Saturday and Sunday at The Test Kitchen
what a Smashburger meat Smashburger is
essentially where you don't take a
temperature on the burger okay I hand
grind the meat myself I select all the
meat so that you know there's no
hormones everything's like really solid
we do a nice smash on it and you get a
crispy Lacy Edge on the side to add
texture to the burger and
It's amazing And when we walked in here
I felt like I was in a restaurant things
were sizzling it's smelling delicious in
here so run me through we're putting the
meat on here and this comes the smash it
comes the smash that's fine
and you'll see it's nice and flat
looking good what is the name of this
burger that you're making right now uh
the name of this burger is just a single
Smash Burger that I do even it's simple
yeah all right as you're cooking away
Jolene too tell us a little bit about
the celebrations that you have going on
this weekend absolutely so for the two
years uh Sunday we're open from 11 to 4.
um we have some of our tenants that are
going to be there serving food in
addition to some guest chefs that have
been with us before so
um if you were there in the beginning
by Nina mancha that Forte is going to be
back with us her food's amazing Chef
Justin Hall is coming in he's done a
couple of pop-ups with us we'll be
serving gumbo this Mama's house is
coming in for appearance Christina new
win we'll have fly Sushi we'll have Down
to Earth so great food we'll have some
live music and then we are doing some um
some charity some charity events so we
have a dunk tank Chef Justin Paul is
going to be in the dong tank it's going
to be a cold plunge okay and you have
the opportunity to dunk him and he is
raising money for the American
Foundation as a suicide prevention for
Nevada wow we're also decorating our
trees so if you want to help us decorate
our tree you can donate to shade tree
and or Noah's Animal Hospital so that's
going on in the alleyway we're bringing
back our glue glue which is our wine
club so you can taste all these amazing
low intervention organic wines wow you
guys have quite the celebration plan
that's all happening this weekend this
burger is smelling and looking amazing I
can't wait to take a bite thank you guys
so much for being here Jolene congrats
thank you thank you so much be sure to
go check out Vegas Test Kitchen anytime
but especially this weekend as they are
celebrating their two-year anniversary
Mercedes also